shanell is with us in charlotte - Elle
how are you oh how are you baby thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up okay so I had a rough
start as far as my credit is concerned
my mom stole my identity before I even
turned 18
so I never even had any type of
financial education whatsoever and I
just recently started listening to your
show I feel a little overwhelmed with
how much said I have at my age and again
listening to your show I don't think I
have the right agree to make a whole lot
of money so I realized that and I went
to real estate school but I failed the
test twice so I have to take it one more
time in order to kind of change my
income levels so I guess my question is
I only need about thirty thousand right
now and I have over a hundred thousand
dollars and that most of it is student
loans it's 105 thousand in student loans
I know that alive and I'm not a doctor I
have a degree in psychology
mm-hm but again it's a lot of
information that I didn't have when I
was making decisions I'm the first one
in my family to go to college if I
didn't have any education on on student
loans and I thought that as many as I
could so that I could survive while I
was in college so that had no financial
support from family and friends not sure
though it was just a terrible cycle on
financially because of not having
information and then still not making
enough money so well you've analyzed
you've analyzed you've analyzed how you
got here very accurately you're very
self aware and that's really great news
for your future how old are you 25 no I
wish and I get that a lot in person so
people think I'm like 21 but I'm
actually 39 I'll be 40 in June ok and
when did you complete your son your
degree in psychology 2007 I've been
working a lot of customer service call
center jobs since then
so you're never really about you've
never really gotten into that into the
field of your degree then no so that
recently I wanted to be a psychologist
but then I did a couple of internships
and feel this is so dart for my
personality I don't think I'm strong
enough to handle other people's problems
in that capacity
um I'd probably take the problems home
with me and end up committing suicide
for five years and I don't want to do
that I don't think that's a plan I agree
with you so you're single yeah you're
single yeah okay you have a hundred and
five thousand dollars in student loan
debt right okay all right well I mean I
think you have eleven dollars from our
repossess vehicle from four years ago
five thousand dollars from an apartment
that I was trying to stay in but it was
over price for me and like two or three
hundred dollars in medical bills so you
got some old bad from the repo and the
eviction and all that kind of stuff all
right yeah and so here's what I always
look at I use big numbers here when I'm
on the air meaning I don't care about
the rounding issues and all that kind of
stuff I look at what I call the shovel
to hole ratio so you're in a hundred and
five thousand really about a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars worth of debt
including everything
versus that's the whole we are in the
shovel is you're in them is a thirty
thousand dollar income and so by the
time you eat and pay rent and pay lights
and just basic existence okay you don't
have a ton of wiggle room so you have a
small shovel you have a small shovel and
a large hole and you've already
recognized that because you're already
working on your career path and saying
what can I do to make more money you're
already thinking that way which is how
you ought to be thinking okay so that's
the route so I think the first thing is
make sure we don't make any more errors
any more borrowing any more messes
and make sure you live on what you have
coming in that's your first thing okay
and then the next thing is as we can get
in come up or squeeze any drops out of
the existing income let's start working
these debts down and just start beating
on them obviously if you could go from
thirty to sixty that entire $30,000
increase would be able to go on this
debt divided into a hundred puts you
three years out of that Wow
see what I'm doing that sounds really
doable yeah so that's not it from my
perspective I'm like it's gonna take me
ten years to get out of it is if you
don't get your income up right but the
good news is life is not a snapshot it's
a film strip the snapshot is today and
the snapshot sucks but it's a film strip
meaning it's ever moving and you're
looking out into the future you're
saying I got to change some stuff I'm
gonna get in the real estate business
I'm going to do the extra wires II I'm
gonna do something that doesn't pay
thirty thousand dollars a year and
because I think cuz a cuz I want a good
life but B the first thing I'm gonna do
with that money when I get some more is
knock these debts out so that I can have
a good life
so you're right on track I think you're
gonna do fine
it's and what you'll hear is you listen
to the debt snowball or the debt free
screams here on the air you'll often
hear people where their incomes went up
dramatically the first hour I had a get
a couple that was six kids that start
out making 60,000 when they started
their desk snowball four years and three
months ago now they make 200 up from 60
the second hour and a couple that paid
off $65,000 and their income during the
time they were getting out of debt went
from fifty to ninety almost double and
so but that's over a period of years not
months and so but as their income went
up they kept their lifestyle at the
original and throw all the extra at the
debt like you and I were just talking
about so I think that's where you're
going I think that's what you're going
to see happen in your life I can see it
real clearly and I'm here to help you I
want you to go through Financial Peace
University as my guest
it's a one-year membership there's nine
lessons that you go the local church and
take the lessons plus all the stuff is
online the audio the video everything is
online and you've got the every dollar
Plus program as well the one-year
membership to that included and I'm
gonna give you all of that because I
really think you need a better future
than you got today and I really think
you're heading that way and I want to be
part of your story so you hold on and
Kelly's gonna pick up and you call me
back as you're working through this if
you need help but Chanelle
the answer is making more money that is
the answer and you already have the
answer for you called me by the way
that's not my answer you already knew
that thanks for the call